das ist klein tommy oder damals einfach
nur tommy was sich aus diesem test
versuchen einmal entwickeln soll war für
ihn hier keine sekunde überhaupt im raum
des möglichen
trotzdem ist es genau diese faszination
die ihnen einmal dazu verleiten wird
alles auf eine karte zu setzen und noch
ganz ohne social media following die
dreizehnte klasse und damit das
allgemeine abitur abzubrechen um seinen
großen traum zu leben welchen trick
könnte man schon fast sagen ich in diese
situation gekommen bin also ich dass wir
machen darf das verrate ich heute aber
in diesen videos soll es eigentlich kann
ich so viele mich gehen sondern viel
mehr um dich um genau zu sein um die
nächste generation von träumer jemand
von euch der lust hat zu mir nach köln
zu ziehen und richtig hauptberuflich an
meinen videos als cutter und kameramann
zu arbeiten aber noch mal zurück zu ihm
hier
wir schreiben das jahr 2010
videoproduktion und visual effects
werden immer zugänglicher und schaffen
es sogar in meinem kinderzimmer
es war einfach das angriffsduo überhaupt
zu sehen wie man am computer die
realität verändern kann
im selben jahr startete und endete der
erste game im kanal zusammen mit philipp
und danach anfang 2014 also mit 15
zusammen mit meinen beiden besten
freunden sebastian und wieder philipp
ein comedy sketch projekt welches aber
ebenfalls noch im selben jahr
eingestellt wird
bis hierhin war das alles so ein cooles
hobby aber hauptsächlich habe ich den
ganzen tag am computer gezockt erst mit
16 hatte ich den drang irgendwas zu
suchen dem ich mein komplettes leben
widmen karten aber nichts gefunden
bis mir aufgefallen ist dass es die
ganze zeit direkt vor meiner nase war
und nicht nur für zu unrealistisch
gehalten haben aber manchmal wussten
ziel ebenso fantastisch und
unrealistisch sein wenn man genug
motiviert ist überhaupt kein arsch hoch
zu kriegen und das habe ich dann gemacht
und 2017 entstand zusammen mit philipp
dieses musikvideo dass ich ganz ehrlich
bis heute als mein meisterwerk ansehe
vier monate zehn stunden am tag ohne
ausnahme filmen schneiden und vor allem
an den visual effects arbeiten und
obwohl ich dem was ich dadurch wirklich
verpasst habe also die partys und
grillabende kurz nach meinem 18
geburtstag während den sommerferien
obwohl ich den echt ein bisschen nach
trauer was genau dieses video bei dem
ich mich dann im august 2017 einfach so
ins blaue
als praktikant beworben haben und eine
antwort bekommen haben ich war zu der
zeit so unfassbar hefti das kann man
sich eigentlich echt überhaupt nicht
vorstellen ich war die ganze zeit so
motiviert und so darauf pochen dass
kasse zu machen
raus in die welt zu gehen und
kohleprojekte zu machen wenn ich doch
nur eine chance bekommen würde und da
war sie julian bern trifft sich mit mir
500 kilometer entfernt in köln und
entscheidet sich für einen anderen
sowas passiert trotzdem war ich zerstört
aber jetzt könnt ihr mich niemand mehr
aufhalten wenn sie ganz schön bleiben
auch seine öffentlich auffindbare
e-mail-adresse reagiert dann werde ich
mit sicherheit jemanden finden dessen
videos schneiden darf und davon sogar
leben kann und das habe ich dann auch
also auf nach berlin wo ich für einen
großen youtuber lesung effects machen
dürfte der traum geht weiter
ich filme mit ihm mache das was ich
liebe arbeite nebenbei an eigenen
projekten als hätte wirklich kaum besser
laufen können und dann hat er mich
plötzlich begeistert und sich nie wieder
bei mir gemeldet
zwei monate nachdem ich eine bewerbung
an seine business e mail geschickt habe
eine antwort von seinem management hrm
events als hätte lust mit ihr
zusammenzuarbeiten und den rest kennt er
ja vielleicht ich konnte nicht wahr wie
komplett mitarbeit balladen wie mir spaß
gemacht hat von ihm viel gelernt und
sind für musik videos und andere
projekte nach namibia und los angeles
geflogen
im gegensatz zu anderen youtube die ihre
kater verheimlichen hat mir wie eine tür
nach der anderen geöffnet und
zweieinhalb jahre später kamen thomas
klie von zwei jahren
aber ungefähr und der davertschule sagt
ey ich perspektive gesehen bin ich so
ungefähr anderthalb zwei jahre bei dir
dann mache ich meinen eigenen kampf und
jetzt ist dieser punkt gekommen wo
thomas sich entschieden hat und jetzt
bist du dran ich suche einen cutter und
kameramann der hier zu mir nach köln
zieht oder schon hier wohnt und das als
vollzeit job macht und da ich weiß dass
die meisten extrem gut schneiden und
filmen können dass sie schon die ganze
zeit auf ihrem eigenen youtube kanal
machen uns das den der kanal auch am
herzen liegt will ich dem auch gar nicht
im weg stehen
zu wissen dass man nach 23 jahren mit
viel arbeit und etwas glück selber von
youtube leben könnte motiviert auch viel
mehr als nur geld zu kriegen uns diese
motive als auch brauchen weil es wird
nicht leicht wir fangen mal an mit den
voraussetzungen du musst natürlich hier
in köln oder nahe umgebung wohnen oder
hierhin ziehen wollen keine angst du
würdest du dann natürlich mit nette
wohnung leisten können
du brauchst extrem gute kenntnisse im
schneiden mit premiere pro sehr gute
kenntnisse in photoshop im idealfall auf
gute kenntnisse in der top 8 effekt und
wenn du dich mit leitung illustrator
grundlegende audiobearbeitung und
sonstigen programmen auskennst ist das
war kein muss aber auf jeden fall allen
vorteilen du musst eine ahnung haben wie
man mit einer kamera umgeht und sachen
gut in szene setzt du brauchst ein
gespür dafür wohin kann die kamera hält
damit dass ein verschwindest bilder gibt
sprich fremming oder komposition und das
nicht nur beim filmen sondern auch bei
fotos vielleicht hast du sogar
erfahrungen mit einem himmel oder einer
drohne wirklich alles in die richtung
wird ihren vorteil verschaffen dann 3d
modeling tracking rendering und so
weiter ist natürlich kein muss und wird
auch wie ihr seht nicht häufig auf dem
kanal passieren aber solltest das können
ist das auf jeden fall nicht schlecht
wenn du dich mit excel oder anderen
organisationsteams oder mit
programmieren auskennst egal wie wenig
das auf den ersten blick mit dem kanal
zu tun hat schreiben die bewerbung ein
guter schulabschluss jetzt für dich egal
aber ich leg tatsächlich sehr viel wert
auf die einstellung zum leben wohin soll
die reise gehen willst du vielleicht
irgendwas sehr wie youtube machen oder
hast du darauf keine lust und wissen
einfach nur schneiden und filmen
interessierst du dich für philosophie
psychologie persönlichkeitsentwicklung
schreibt die bewerbung lieblingszitat
schreibt rhein gibt es menschen da
draußen denen du folgst du dich
inspirieren
der weise helfen gibt es youtube videos
songs musikfilme den besonderen einfluss
auf dein leben hatten wer oder was
inspiriert dich im merkt schon
letztendlich suchen jemanden der richtig
gut schneiden und filmen kann aber auch
jemand der hier gut ins umfeld passt und
hohe erwartungen an sich selbst und sein
leben hat du musst natürlich über 18
sein oder es zumindest in den nächsten
zwei monaten werden weiß ich jetzt
irgend jemand denken sollten auf dem
moment habe ich mein ganzes leben lang
dann kannst du jetzt folgendes tun klick
auf den link in der video beschreibung
und lade sie in den ordner mit ganz
vielen daten herunter das sind bestimmt
über 100
also könnte sein dass es zum zeitpunkt
des videos noch nicht online ist der
links der steht dann spätestens morgen
also am 17 september da drin in dem
ordner ist dann auch eine pdf in der
genau steht was du tun musst lest euch
das unbedingt durch aber jetzt schon mal
ganz grob zusammengefasst ist ja auch
wieder entspannt als erstes nimmt ein
video auf wodurch ganz kurz 30 sekunden
vor der kamera vorstellt dann schneidest
du mit dem film als dewey herunterladen
wirst die ersten zwei minuten von einem
haupt video mit hilfe von dem skript
aber sehr gerne kreativ wenn du denkst
du wirst von script abweichende danach
das unbedingt im download link wird auf
musik sein aber bonuspunkte gibt auf
jeden fall wenn ihr selber bmx-rad liest
passende und copyright freie musik
selber findet dann erstellst du zu dem
video und damit wir sehen dass du auch
mit leichter den themen gut umgehen
kannst und dazu lustige musik und alles
mögliche findest ist eine der aufgaben
auch noch eine zweiminütige streaming
haider zu zaubern und dazu dann auch
noch zusammen das vorstellen dann wäre
es gut wenn du dir 3 video ideen
überlegen würde ist von denen du denkst
dass die auf einem kanal richtig gut
passen würden und natürlich gut ankommen
würden dann schreibst du die rein ist
der video ideen und schreibst die erste
minute von dem skript würde damit ich
eine einschätzung krieg ob du im schnitt
dann auch vielleicht eine geschichte
erzählen kannst ohne dass man die an
skript vorgibt sucht ja noch gerne zwei
drei kurze stücke von einer arbeit es
könnten auch bilder seien oder
irgendwelchen musikvideos packt alles an
den ordner und latz unseres link
hochland schreibst du dir die bewerbungs
vorlage punkt txt höchstes mit deinen
inhalten aus und schickt es dann ab aber
ließ er davor auf jeden fall noch die
carta info punkt pdf durch weil er so
ein wichtiger inhalte wie jetzt hier den
rahmen sprengen würden ich weiß das ist
ultra fif lang für den bewerbungen und
ihr werdet daran bestimmt ein oder zwei
oder sogar drei tage dann sitzen und die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir dann eine
absage bekommt die bestehen natürlich
also wenn es euch das nicht wäre es dann
lass das natürlich seien auf die besten
der bewerbungen würde ich dann reagieren
und szenen schau doch geben wenn sie das
möchten also statt bitte in den betreff
reaktion ja oder reaktion ein damit wir
das direkt wissen ob ihr das eine
reaktion zeigen dürfen oder nicht wenn
ihr noch nicht schneiden könnte oder
noch ein anfänger seitz dann kann ich
euch mal ein schnittkurs empfehlen mit
dem man innerhalb von zwei stunden
videomaterial möglichst effizient und
schnell alles braucht dass man für
youtube videos und musik videos braucht
aber ganz wichtig ich will euch keine
illusionen machen kauft euch das ding
wirklich nur wenn ihr selber wirklich
schneiden lernen wollt und nicht wenn
ihr jetzt mein kater werden wollt weil
was der kater alles können muss das land
in zwei wochen auf gar keinen fall an
dieser stelle nochmal ein großes danke
meinen aktuellen cutter den barney der
immer großartige arbeit leistet aber
leider nicht nach köln ziehen kann er
hat vor kurzem ein video gemacht
kehrt wie er meinte aber auch der von
anderen youtuber geworden ist und er
macht videos zum thema schnitt und film
also wenn auch das interessiert dann
findet ihr auch dahin link in der
beschreibung ich freue mich jetzt schon
eure bewerbungen zu sehen ich bin mir
sicher noch viele gibt die jetzt zögern
und ich wissen ob sie diesen schritt
wagen sollen oder ob sie nach köln
ziehen wollen und für die wenn ich
dieses video mal komplett klischeehaft
mit einer rede von steve jobs
[Musik]